we're going to talk a little bit about
how robots learn but more specifically
perhaps
well how autonomous vehicles or
self-driving
vehicles let me begin with sort of our
conception of what it means for a robot
to learn
or even to just know anything people are
often mystified when we say you know a
robot is learning and and people say no
only only children can learn only people
can learn what's a robot doing
maybe the first question to ask is what
does a robot need to know in order to do
anything useful
so you mentioned self-driving cars what
do we need to know
as a car in order to be able to drive we
need to know
what is a road what is not a road what
is an obstacle what's not an obstacle
which is literally the very minimum you
must know before you can do anything at
all the robot must know
how the car behaves so what happens if i
press this pedal what happens if i turn
the steering wheel a little bit so these
are all physical systems if you like
of one kind or the other how the car
behaves is literally what we are taught
in high school physics
so the robot must have some idea of high
school physics we don't mean
make a robot sit there and learn like we
did
but but some of that information about
what will happen if you do something
must be in the robot
likewise uh the robot needs to
understand you know
if i see the these kind of perceptions
it
it must be the road and and it needs to
be
able to do this robustly you know under
rain under snow
under all of these conditions lighting
so these are all
uh you know bits of knowledge that the
robot needs
likewise uh you also need to know as the
robot
what will somebody do if i do this now
when somebody
starts to break and you see their brake
light what should i expect just as what
should i expect if i press this pedal
and then once you understand that then
you say okay if i expect this then what
can
i do so maybe i can cut in front of this
person because they have slowed down
and maybe i can indicate to see if they
let me in
and so on and so forth so the knowledge
gets more and more sophisticated until
at the very limit you're trying to ask
what kind of a person
am i facing and all of this is knowledge
so when we say a robot learns
what we mean is that the robot has some
kind of a representation of these bits
of knowledge
it could be a map it could be a function
that says if you do this this will
happen
and then what the robot is doing is
changing something in the representation
to better
fit what it sees in reality that's what
learning is in any industry
they have the saying rubbish in rubbish
out so
how much information do you need to feed
these before they can make some kind of
sense of it
i mean because we are talking about cars
and how they learn
it's very interesting because at the
moment uh the
the biggest barrier that the industry as
a whole faces is to get enough data to
represent everything
at one level if you're thinking about
what's the minimum you need to learn
uh or you need to know in order to get
started it's not a whole lot
uh in fact i mean think about it this
way so we have
uh you know high school students come in
for
weekend hackathons and we get them to
take lego
lego robots and follow a line on the uh
you know on the floor
uh and it's not that hard uh it's so
people can put these together
in a more serious note it's an
undergraduate project to get a car to
just follow the road somewhere
but that's not what we are talking about
when we say self-driving cars what we're
really talking about is a car
that can cope with multiple conditions
multiple environmental kind of behaviors
different actors on the road
unknowns in the form of you know maybe a
paper bag flying in front of you
and is that a rock or is it just a paper
bag that i can drive through
by the time you're talking about all of
this you need an enormous amount of data
or you need some way in which people can
teach you efficiently
so when we were taught how to drive we
were leveraging common sense that we had
learned over a lifetime
but also people gave us rules so people
told us you know
make sure that you know somebody else is
not in your way
and and they didn't just show you one or
two examples they gave you this high
level instruction
that covered a lot of things so
sometimes that's how you get good data
it's it's
a combination of all of these there's
obviously got to be a huge amount of
processing going on here as well
how do you deal with that amount of data
and how
you know the amount of processing that's
required with a lot of
care and with a lot of resources
so in terms of resources so to give you
an example if
if you drove around the car with let's
say eight cameras and radar and lidar
units
and if you drove it around all day nine
to five by the end of the day you'd have
accumulated enough information
that you wouldn't use wi-fi or something
to transmit it you would unplug the hard
disk and
you know plug it back in that's the
level at which uh
information is gonna be collected uh one
can be clever about this this is what
computer science is about so one can
curate compress uh all of that uh but
ultimately uh what you really want is
many many months and years of campaigns
like this in many places
all of that compressed and distilled and
that's what the frontier of machine
learning today is
i'm just imagining those gigabytes of
data and and what
will you do with them but i mean
presumably a lot of the processing has
to happen in real time
and then what you're talking about is
perhaps analyzing that
information is it the acquisition has to
be real time because you don't know at
one time what is useful and what is not
but we are not the first kind of
industry in robotics to think about this
so if you take as an example what's
going on with these big particle
accelerators they're doing exactly the
same thing
you know they they conduct this
experiment they don't know what happened
uh it it everything happens so fast that
they're collecting terabytes of data for
you know fractions of a second uh and
then they have a
a high resolution very fast layer that
quickly
does a basic level of processing and all
of the analysis happens afterwards
so it would be a little bit like that in
this pipeline as well it's definitely
not the first time i've said it so
apologies if you're bored of hearing
this
but it seems to me that the the big
problem with anything that's autonomous
is actually mixing it with things that
are not autonomous
if you change everything overnight to be
autonomous you just implement some rules
and off you go but
how do you make sense of a world where
some things are not acting
in the same way you do this is exactly
what is making this problem interesting
because
as you say if if all vehicles on the
road were autonomous if there were no
people running around
and there were no kids jumping in front
of you the problem is much simpler then
we really have just the tcp protocol for
your computer
uh just running on physical uh
you know packets and and that would be
much simpler it wouldn't be trivial but
we understand those problems
what makes this problem hard is exactly
that you need to understand
what is the person in front of me doing
if i see this if i
think this is what they're doing and i
do this what will they do
and all of that that complexity is what
the robot needs to cope with
the way we do it in practice is that we
take a combination of
behave a little bit conservatively you
know assume that the other person
uh you know might be doing things you
don't fully understand
assume if you're going in a school zone
that a kid could you know jump in front
of you so
act a little bit conservatively is a
good uh starting heuristic
and the second is to learn over time in
the beginning maybe we don't know what
people are doing but after a while
you've seen
enough number of instances that maybe
some of these things aren't a surprise
anymore
and over time slowly you've
understood all of what we call edge
cases
different countries people behave in
different ways so
would these autonomous vehicles have to
be localized in some way
they would they are quite far away i
think uh from the point when country
level
kind of behavioral nuances matter
because there are much bigger problems
that are still unsolved
uh there certainly are differences so
one prominent difference so
i spent many years living in the us and
then now i've spent many years living in
the uk
and a big difference is uh you know
walking on the
on the street jaywalking as it's called
is illegal
in most parts of the us but it's not
illegal
in the uk and in fact we have a
completely different approach to
transportation regulation on that front
this makes a big difference for the car
because you can make certain assumptions
in one setting that you cannot make in
another setting
and also the importance of do you need
models of how people behave
uh changes because of this uh so like
this there are a number of differences
so if you're in an uh you know suburban
environment where lane discipline is all
you need driving is a lot simpler
if you're in a tight urban setting in
which you have to
squeeze your way in and things like that
driving is much harder
and i know that um there are trails
going on there are places where you can
use
autonomous vehicles or at least in a
limited fashion
but just before you mention that there
is still someone solve problems so what
what the biggest um
unsolved problems in this area i think
what people are struggling with
is this business of edge cases uh so so
uh at one level the way it manifests
itself is that when something slightly
odd happens
you know somebody didn't stop the way
you thought they should
or maybe people double parked in a way
that you weren't expecting
these things can confuse the system
because it hasn't been trained in quite
that setting i think most road trials
and most serious players have
gotten past this these kinds of problems
have been solved
but the next level of problems now is
you know how do you interact with people
in a meaningful way
so one of my students and i we recently
wrote a paper in which we were arguing
that
you know the act of driving is
fundamentally an act of conflict uh
anybody who's seriously driven would
immediately agree uh
it may you know it may not seem that way
uh up front
but but that's naturally what it is you
know every time we give way
every time you know somebody pushes in
it just a little bit faster so that they
go first
they're all situations of conflict mild
conflict i mean
nothing too bad but but it's still
something that the agent must learn to
deal with
uh in turn this calls for uh interesting
mathematical techniques so there are
fields like game theory that
try to describe these kinds of phenomena
and so
one could look at how do you bring those
kinds of constructions along with
you know modern driven machine learning
uh reasoning methods
so people are looking at a variety of
ways in which one could tackle this
the edge cases we're sort of getting
getting beyond
but i mean i suppose there are edge
cases where humans fail and make
problems otherwise
we wouldn't have any accidents on the
road or collisions um
what is the holy grail in this field
what is it that everyone's striving to
to solve so people are struggling to say
what it means to be competent
some of it is actually social acceptance
and political realities
uh so so there needs to be a
conversation at the societal level about
you know now that these technologies are
looking serious what do we want
i don't think that conversation has
fully happened yet uh so for the longest
time this was just quaint technology
happening in a few places
uh then it got picked up in the
political circles as this is emerging
technology but i
i think we still have not had
conversation sitting down with the
layperson
you know ultimately the people who are
going to be affected are people who
don't even know what this technology is
you know kids and elderly and so on
uh so that conversation has to happen
for one
version of this answer but but if you
kind of think about it in terms of what
do the engineers and the technologists
think is the holy grail i would say
at the minimum we would like you know
robust autonomy in what we call
you know operating design domains that
are large enough
you know so right now one might say we
only drive if it's sunny
or we only drive between nine to five
uh and that's okay and you could imagine
kind of operating vehicles like this
but we want these conditions to be
reasonably permissive that it's useful
it's economically useful and we're not
quite there because
you know in in the uk if you said i'm
only going to drive if it's sunny you're
not going to run a very useful business
uh so you have to be able to at least
cope with weather conditions and then
you have to be able to cope with traffic
conditions then you have to cope with
seasonality
and so so the the holy grail is really
to be able to include all of this in the
design domain
there's a slightly out there question i
want to put to you
that some of these um cars
vehicles have got so much computation on
is it not more efficient just to have a
human sitting there
this is an excellent question at the
moment uh
i would say that a lot of that
computation is there because we don't
know how to solve the problem in a
collaborative way
uh also a lot of that computation is
just commercial grade
you know regular computers that have
been put there because nobody has built
a special purpose unit
for people who are serious i mean a very
good example is tesla where they've
expended an enormous model effort to
make it a product
that's compact and kind of sellable and
and they've made good progress
um so like that i think when
when the full uh you know manufacturing
enterprise is dedicated to this problem
some of this will get better so we'll
have uh raspberry pi
running our uh that i do not know uh
what i would really expect is that you
know the the big players whether it's an
nvidia or an intel or
whoever the new entrant is i would not
be surprised if
uh you know they all don't have plans
for how exactly you're going to come up
with an embedded systems platform
that is more compact than what's going
around so if you looked at some of the
early days of autonomous driving they
just
you know pc units uh you know
bought from commercial suppliers and
just stacked in the back
uh so clearly that's not how you want to
run this uh
but that's also clearly just a matter of
the big players not having done
something for it
one of the classic things to ask anyone
who's talking about any technology is
does it ever go wrong um and it's kind
of
we read in the newspapers occasionally
that some of these trials go wrong
does it putting aside the you know the
tragic cases where it's goes horribly
wrong
what's the sort of thing that it might
it just gets slightly wrong
is there something that just continually
crops up
it does and and in fact those are the
more interesting ones
to give you a very trivial example
hesitation at roundabouts
uh so you might have a car uh you know
that wants to acquire enough information
and and only then enter a roundabout but
if you
if you look carefully they look like you
know student drivers who annoy everybody
on the road
right and they're not quite going in and
like no
you can go now i would have gone but
then the car doesn't go
and if you're in a dense enough area
this might mean that you hold up traffic
this is not quite called a failure in
public discussion but it is a failure
and until you can solve these kinds of
problems you're not going to get
acceptance
but i suppose that different autonomous
vehicles could communicate with each
other and make
is that how it would work it could work
this is an issue that's not
explored nearly enough but i'm beginning
to think more and more that it's only a
matter of time
it's only really a matter of time before
something like this also comes in
so the real reason it's not explored at
the moment is that
it takes a certain amount of
infrastructure cost
for the you know street signs the roads
uh everything to be instrumented but in
the scheme of things if you think about
the
you know number of billions and you know
nearly trillions that are going to be
spent on infrastructure
all the big countries are seriously
thinking about it uh
then it's not inconceivable that we can
put in place technologies like this and
if we did we would completely
uh you know change the game for the
amount of intelligence that's needed
of course because there's so much
computer vision going on at the moment
is gps not sufficient then an up-to-date
map and gps
no that was the early days so in the
early days uh
people started out with you know i have
gps and and
in fact that the in the beginning
when this problem was being looked at
the most interesting and exciting area
of artificial intelligence that was
being applied here was
called simultaneous localization and
mapping can you figure out the map as
you're driving and then having figured
out that map can you figure out where
you are on that map
and that that field has grown
spectacularly it's become extremely
robust
but as i was saying at the beginning
that only tells you where is the road
and where are you on the road it doesn't
really tell you what's the other car
going to do
how should i actually drive what happens
when i get stuck in a roundabout
you know all of these other things that
we teach learner drivers
all of that still needs to be solved a
door in front of it so the belief
would be updated to say that i'm
probably here
here we just talk about five roads
because i've always been
here a little bit longer then we've got
60 possible positions
one we've got a two three out of five
and then they can all go in any slot